alors je suis pas de retour encore je te
laisse bon mais pas ta caméra pour le
monde va avoir déjà ça je ne veux jamais
pas là bas pas tout de suite on va voir
juge le voir je le contrôler que ça
marche bien qu'ils m'entendent bien et
tout ça en fait c'est pas si bien tu
grésy re jeu grésy ouais ouais tu veux
mais tu désires prime c'est peut-être
mon jeu lancé mais ta caméra pour voir
bon alors on ne va pas grésillés non ça
va watteco [ __ ] quoique je suis juste
je sais pas pourquoi je suis très juste
bah écoute pour une raison qui m'a
inconnu j'ai une mauvaise connexion
internet aujourd'hui
et jusqu'où
barret comment on fait je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne comprends pas pourquoi
mais du coup tu veux faire un 4 échecs
je suis en train de mon côté mais
attends je vais essayer de te trouver et
ce qu'est ce qu'on peut regarder les
parties de quelqu'un d'autre en quatre
échecs le nom de 4,2 alors attends
tonnes guerraoui attends je peux trouver
les parties donc peut-être tu peux
trouver en fait
faby me tiens t'es là à je te vois c'est
génial et bleu ouais t'as les bleus
c'est un mec qui a déjà abandonné tout
seul quoi
bref je déteste quand il ya un mec qui
abandonne bailly s'est déconnecté comme
un idiot alors attentats les bleus mais
était une bonne pause là non tu es bien
ouais bah sauf que je vais marquer zéro
point il ya un mais quatre jeunes dames
et l'autre il a déjà maté un roi qui
surabondent un mec donc quelque part
c'est un peu chiant mais bon c'est pas
mal là il fait n'importe quoi mais quand
jeanne il est vraiment nul car je peux
lui bouffer b2 à tout moment par la
batterie je m'en fous 17 mai j'ai pas
envie jamais changé les fous moi je
regardais mes pièces sans fatigue m'en
fous complètement
ça ma stratégie de début de partie où en
fait je joue tout seul en fait je n'ai
rien même pas ce que les autres font je
ne veux pas voir manger de trucs mars
donc d'avoir la triche je pousse les
pions j'ai l'impression que là depuis
qu'on est partie du truc duchess points
comme quand même sur les quatre échecs
ya plus aucun frais de connexion la
jeunesse comme veut qu'on résout quatre
échecs non mais t'as vu ça ça marche
bien ça grésille encore ou pas non en
fait je pense qu'il ya trop de gens qui
étaient connectés sur le truc pour
regarder les le machin des ordis et je
pense que ça faisait absolument donner
mon ordinateur en fait parce que depuis
que je suis partie du truc de
tchatche.com live enfin c'est fini quoi
tout marche très bien en fait pas j'ai
l'impression en tout cas je passe à toi
de me dire amen je bloque un peu la main
tu ne veux pas te pleurons ne reste que
du coup c'est mes filles est ce que tu
peux nous expliquer les règles de ce
truc ouais bah ce qui compte c'est
marqué des points hier en bouffant des
pièces adverse ou en matant des rois
donc on dirait un autre tour dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre
donc c'est jaune après sévère bon
véhicule à une faune et solidaire il est
guéri maintenant parce qu il suffit les
marques et ya rouge aussi nom qui est la
cité puis en huitièmes rangés comme aux
échecs classique tu fais une dame mais
que si tu te fais bouffer tadam
promulgue ça ne marque qu'un point vos
adversaires alors ta vraie dame marque
10 points donc attention et marqué 9
points entre dames neuf bourses question
paraît pas tout à fait né à nantes et en
gros le mec est à gauche toujours très
dangereux
c'est en gros si je fais chaque âge
jaune non art où je veux dire sera pas
le tempo
car jaune pourra jouer un coup j'ai
assisté cheikh john peut attaquer saddam
bon ben il va il a été mon échec et
jonah hill bouffer la dame après il faut
toujours faire gaffe aux vins catag au
chili sournois quoi même si mec
normalement mais c'est le mec dangereux
de la position mais là t'es pas un peu
mal dans le sens où tu joues contre un
tête à tête et était dans le mauvais
quartier des chéquiers quoi parce que tu
as chaud plus fâché pas quelle couleur
était le mec bas le vert non mais c'est
un peu con que oui nommer que ces
déconnecté votre coup aux côtes moindre
outil d'épargné ferme moi je pousse mes
pions boyer sur ces thèmes ranger la
times option ils menacent une dame
okocha là on me dit ça sert mais ça ça
ne sert plus à rien mangé les pièces du
gris en fait mais alain le graissage
marque zéro point après juste ces pièces
sont là les entraves des trucs au moins
la sentra pas grand chose une partie des
chics et qui va servir à rien et est en
passe de faire dame et puis l'autre
citoyenne ne bloquez il joue en
coédition l'un et l'autre contre moi ils
se sont écrit j'aurais dû dire cdp dé
quoi bon ok bon accueil à faire mais je
suis très attention c'est bon à savoir
mais c'est juste chiant que les mecs qui
jouent à deux contre un donc talent
rouge qui jouait avec le jaune contre
après moi même mais
en fait je veux dire qu'ils veulent te
battre et après se jouer la partie entre
eux en faites pas je sais pas ce qu'ils
font bon on s'en fout un mot quand tu
d'avancé mais en fait tu ne rentres en
conflit avec personne toi et moi c'est
mon intérêt de vendre leur entrée en
coupe mais entre vous la des rouges des
jaunes
faites-vous mal que vos pièces
disparaissent apparent ramasse tout à la
petite cuillère qu'est ce que c'est que
ce qu'il y ait aissa vous que trois
points
par contre bon bah écoute hymne attaque
mon truc va défendre mais c'est hyper
chaud il ya des pièces de partout où il
ya beaucoup de mal à tous les sens c'est
fantastique
il attaque son cavalier jaune avec
bochum 1 mélanie l'a pas vu ça va
dégager sinon on peut chez thfr dame tu
vas te punit pas sauf si rouge le fait
de menaces il me sera chiante mais ça ça
me saoule en fait ça fait vieux pousser
une prendre la chaîne de pions noter un
spa tout ça bon je t'aime et l'encaissé
regarde ménard bien que jaune non mes
pieds je la préférais ne peut faire ça
car seul johnny tu en veux pas je sais
pas si jamais je préfère n'avoir aucun
pompier que personne bon moment le mec
laisse des cavaliers emprise faut quand
même punir ou la france d'ouvrir son roi
nos glaciers pénible ces six rouges il
te prends ton pu en fait parce que du
mental une attaque mais c'est après son
pion gens fous ça ça m'embête plus en
fait je préfère qu'ils prennent l'option
que ce rouge il va vers l'avant pour lui
la tabula d'humour à 7 12 10 la réaction
tout ce qui fait rien quand il ya tête
la chaîne de la base d'options dont j'ai
ramené le foot le défendre tout ça mais
bon ça m'intéresse pas noté l'a changé
quoi je veux garder toutes mes pièces
alors si on veut on voit les points de
chaque voir juste les points du rouge on
les voit pas sur l'écran là il amenait à
20 points
si le matin avec un arrêt là c'est relou
les échanges ça ne m'intéresse pas les
affaires vous prendre avec lui bah oui
mais moi je veux pas y changer
mais taper vous entre bourges et je ne
viens pas m'embêter poussaï la dame là
bas il est qu'on puisse juger sur son
nez le roi il n'ya pas y'a pas le vert
comme empêché de faire des dames de
partout avec exception à chez baader ce
que je vais enfin le faire et lui vient
juste d'entrer dans la zone de conflit
au mode art est intacte de partout que
c'est horrible honnart de merde langage
salary père énervé que ça n'intéresse
pas le mec joue mal à me saouler pour
rien ils m'attaquent et madame 7e faire
perdre des temps le sang chaud qui sait
si son prochain coup ouais ils
m'attaquent états d'âme et en fait des
juges je vais la bouger ça en fait là
aussi le jeu il y avait bien joué ils
auraient pu te prendre ton pions avec
saddam en fait oui veut faire des coûts
chez un homme c'est exactement mais bon
les mecs salam et a13 allons c'est pas
des génies heureusement la s et es sears
était sûre il va ta taille au sol il ça
ne sert à rien de plus et un prix va te
faire un cavalier
non mais c'est juste chiant fait tu peux
pas jouer en fait le mieux mais qui s'en
prend à toi tu sais tu n'as aucune
raison pourquoi en fait je ne sais pas
mais qui justifie pas du coup je vais
perdre et enjeux au niveau de ce
championnat dame tranquille important
attend mais ça c'est horrible en fait
quand tu rentres avons fait avec un mec
c'est le pire et moi je rentre en
conflit c'est lui qui vient mon maire
des adrets chez toi je te pleurer
c'était sûr il va attaquer temps fou
c'était sûr j'aurais bien et tu peux pas
aller gratter le pion du jaune là bas
dans la diagonale à vous annoncer le
prochain coup enfin je sais pas
peut-être bons rails et nous réalisons
par deux dames
et puis rouge pays très content encore
patrick adam silver kébé 5,9 et je pense
que les deux ex wali kot je savais pas
trop trop pourquoi le mec c'est encore
perdre du temps comment expliquer
autrement de jouer aussi mal a juste le
mec qui sait juste parce que tu es vers
la gauche à la fin j'ai perdu une partie
pareil le mec il bouge comme est bon et
juste une fait disparaître un fou quoi
pas de mec mode all in pour mélo dauphin
une dame pendant c'est ça c'est que toi
tu es en train d'échanger le tueur 40
dame mais tu ne peux rien faire contre
un crétin un essai qui tape y aura jra
ok je vais contacter tout comme le faire
bannir
il y ajoute avoir sait pas jouer tout à
fait à l'aise c'est horrible bosses il a
échangé le foot mais prendre le pas du
joli
on peut dire à quel point les mecs sont
sans quoi le pédalage s'attaque encore
un cavalier maintenant je me fais
attaquer et le pion par jaune et le
cavaly par marc ayrault sueur
fantastique qu'est ce qu'on fait non mes
écrits je te des changes c'est pas con
petit jouet là je comprends plus ce que
je veux faire
non mais c'est pas parce que tu as le
plus gros lots en fait ben ali alors
c'est un bon vieux coûtent toujours
qu'on se le dise qu'on est en fait j'ai
pas ce que tu peux faire la tma bas au
quai des belges poitou ses fonctions dès
quoi mais bon ça il va me voler mon
cavalier seul tu as pas français qui se
rendent dans des échanges massif le tri
là c'est de la bouche mais pions je peux
rien faire avec joie deux contre un mais
vont aussi jaune et malin mais bon il
est pas mal non plus mais il va il peut
essayer d'aller mater les rouges tout
avril et il ya trois dames pour
l'instant avec quand même là mais rouge
les biens protégés jusqu'à composer
changé d'âme à son tour ouais mais c'est
très intelligent puisque du coup lui
c'est un pion bah je savais je vais pas
les changer mais j'ai tout une voiture
une fois encore par des tanks mais en
fait si la le rouge
i te jarrier tout son piquant ce soit
l'aspect nîmes il pousse ses pions dans
sa dame seule pulsion juste échangé jeu
qu'en grèce qui fait là bas coûts cette
dernière ben non mais ho qui joua de
contrat je te jure que je vois pas
d'autres explications pour que les mecs
jouent comme ça la partie ça n'a aucun
sens sans la section et les uns et les
autres mais c'est peut-être une alliance
tacite sortes d'alliances mais je me
suis fait de la même manière en fait
comme ça ça n'a aucun sens mais en fait
je suis pareil dans le sens oui
tu te retrouves en diagonale face aux
deux ils jouent tous ils vont vers toi
ils ont fait la même chose
taquet pourquoi tu vas y là il est une
tour sur la colonne c'est une dame et il
est bien quoi 28 ans mais n'était plus
un peu à quoi va le défoncer
un motet c'est comme si tu vois à risque
ou à des jeux comme ça des fois tu as
des sortes d'alliances et tu peux à
d'autres contraints défense et avec quoi
ok ça continue peut alors leur connerie
elle al'avantage avec la dame du jeune
elle protège ton pions bref je sens
qu'il met que votre chien il va comme
fer dans le premier set il soit me faire
perdre mais bon juste il perd une dame
pour rien mais bon sinon vie me fait
perdre
bref cette dame prend à vii et lotir
tour reprend un carnavaleux va juste
jaune au dessus d'une dame points non
mais attendez ça continue à faire
n'importe quoi
bah ils te prends un cavalier entre une
dame qui vont à oui mais c'est mais
c'est débile
enfin c'est nos instances se mettre à la
place des ternes entier à faire des
dames
ça ça vaut cher en fait des temps pour
que c'est on surprend c'est tout et fait
la dame d'ottawa quelque chose que tu
peux pas en faire ça mais six jours
ensemble il aurait joué différemment
non mais je joue pas ensemble mais ils
jouent ensemble sans le savoir ils sont
cools son idiot mais en fait la cij ou
bien jauni de faits d'armes trempions
enfin quinting l'a publiquement
on comprend qu'en fait tu pouvais tu
pouvais pas faire dame prend et tout ça
tu étais hyper là j'allais faire du bail
mais bon il tord effet le rouge ferait
en fait d'un cran en fait tu aurait
perdu une dame
ouais c'est ça et j'aurais leurs
emplettes
non mais c'est fou que j'ai envie de
jouer une partie normale les mecs on
n'apportait pas bon allez tombe de haut
niveau mais changer encore une dame la
récente attaque la tour c'est horrible
j'ai défoncé de tous les côtés une
bombasse père mais je comprends pas
l'intérêt qu'il a fait et je te dise
quoique moins idiot tu peux pas jouer
quand ta dose idiot que deux jeux contes
comme non mais là là là le fait
d'échanger la dame c'est vraiment idiot
enfin autant mais pourquoi il prend pas
ton fief est en fait je comment va il
fait dame préemption et tu es en pls en
fait ouais mais bon ok ils ont droit
d'essayer de jouer un coup pour une fois
pas contre moi quoi c'est pas le but du
jeu de l'année sur l'a50 contrôle quoi
mais j'avais détesté la photo je m'étais
retrouvé dans le même temps le même cas
de figure que que ça j'avais détesté la
partie c'était insupportable le problème
c'est à cause du gris en fait c'est le
gris qu'il faut si la partie il s'est
connecté trois zones il a perdu et
définissez point rouge
on veut que tu veux défendre mon point
faible mais tu es mal un terrain sueur
on va voir des médias on est mal on n'a
que deux dames c'est des autres sont en
coalition ils s'affrontent pas il est
plus trop de pièces jacquot a encore un
fou de tournon ses chances passe à
camphin c'est beaucoup moins que les
autres qu'est ce que c'est ce qu'il aime
ce qui vient je sais pas je ne comprends
plus mais utilise stade à un point à
pour aller au delà
je pense qu'elle fait elle bouge à mieux
me faire cavalier machin virer mathworks
van damme est encore megan sous les
coups en fait il va jouer guerrier au
milieu où j'aurai mais tu t'en fiches
bah ouais mais bon par moments c'est
juste chiant il n'a pas fait une menace
à jaune de la partie
la jeune femme tombe un bagage non mais
ok mais ça va prendre le roi pas un
bouche à tous alors je vais faire ça
tu as ta tour bah je prends de la dame
bassij rouge à jour tu as on leur donne
on va perdre des temps quoique ça va
faire un carton
bon il faut les prendre à cette ses
chiens on n'est pas très bien
il a 34 points et c'est que ça comme ça
sert il veut prendre le cavalier mais
bon je m'en fous je reprends un temps
fou à et vous l'avez prendrait mais bon
c'est un peu débile anciens de faire le
mec on a vu que c'était peu de lumière
comme les retours ok tu reprend
l'avantagé aux points mais du coup la
télé gagnant je pense tu as plus de
pièces que lui non pas ceux auxquels ils
jouent beaucoup mieux aux échecs
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qui est
sacrément ridicule je peux faire une
dame au prochain coup d'ailleurs en son
nom mais c'est bon c'est gagné
et le toujours machin pour pousser ses
pions à gta sur d'éditer 100% gagnant
mais tu te trouves pas bien mais ok j'ai
remarqué à utiliser la même chose que
moi aussi je pense que je suis mal bien
ce jeu nous enchaîne le temps m pamela
lyon / pouvoir non mais là je sais qu'on
me cite le sacrifier madame pour les
défoncer son sens qu'est ce que c'est
que ce coût à défoncer son centre c'est
quoi ces banques ont fini en fait savoir
le fou qui rentre dans la diagonale qui
arrivait de mater ou tués note l'ajout
bout mais inquiète a eu beaucoup de
chance que jaune soit soit déconnecté
ouais bon là c'était quand même pas
boire une autre on va essayer de jouer
contre 4 mecs déjà pas trois noms mais
on est quatre en fait ce sont marrants
alors ça joue pas tout de suite mais bon
tu étais en sueur à banon mais j'ai
encore plus quand c'est déloyal quoi les
mecs je vous contre toi de lui faire
objectivement tu es d'accord que c'était
pas prévu ça c'est a annoncé ben oui
mais bon ça ne l'est pas non mais sa
famille en sueur voilà très bien il
utilise ce soir non ouais alors you
d'autres arrivent à bon dieu pour faire
petit rock of ages et 6 rouges et cette
méthode au risque alors à temps pour le
moment je n'ai pas trouvé un viser les
commentaires sur la chaîne mc sont pas
contents quand on montre il faut prendre
la tête du groupe 6 kilos fu il est
clair il fallait montrer c'est après f5
quoi je pourrais pas te comportes valide
ce matin de laurent way et ben quand
c'est fou pranger 5e se passe ici on
fait f5 pour qu'elles élèvent 5 enfants
j'essaie de ne pas prendre le four
angers 7 pouces et de piété matin là tu
te fais ma terrain je suis touche pas
aux fins de gérard gelas cette mesure à
fond ce genre de questions non mais a
fait à ce moment là oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe e4 10 5 qui on prend d'un coup on
s'est pas montrée roi ou de quoi [ __ ]
c'est compliqué a tenté jaune à la roma
4 suiveurs je suis vert à thé vert je
suis vert et est donc comme d'hab y'a un
mec qui a poussé à fond faire une dame
amelia bien personne personne n'a
empêché bas à toi non plus non mais moi
j'ai décidé au point de mettre en
conflit entre ces nouvelles idées je
fais des apps que normand j'étais à la
diagonale du fou fou vers fou rouge la
case blanche fou
ouais je la ferme
non mais je dis voilà on s'en fout mais
enfin j'ai vu ça comme ça en fait fin
voilà on pousse quoi mais là tu es papa
doc et bougies ça intéresse peut-être
pas d'échanger les fous juste pourrait
changer quoi non mais peut-être que
peut-être que là tu as des mecs femme
kate a que des mecs bien classés là ils
sont tous qu'un 116-107 chaud comme
parti
ça a été une période très intéressante
peut se passer un truc c'est qu'à un
moment c'est n'importe quoi tout bloqué
partout j'ai déjà vu ça
tu sais vers quel grand maître
international est fan de ce jeu est joué
assez souvent
ouais ben ameur ouais maintenant ils
vont site web
mais il me donne son fou comme c'est que
gb cette emprise bon sens toujours
bonjour à toi de moi j'ai pas de nom
mais il n'a pas pu voir la liste rouge à
la diagonale c'est pas possible je veux
faire ça maintenant je sais dit je ne
veux pas confus je gardais mes pièces
monde mais tu penses qu'il a vu qu'ils
pouvaient pas faire fou prend un coup de
foudre en baisse s est pas possible
un schéma peut-être d'autres ports par
un temps joué comme ça c'est dangereux
parce qu'en fait je pourrais je pourrais
m'en foutrais dire bah tiens il ya un
fou je le prends et peut-être bien joué
mais c'était quand même cinq points donc
c'est le fou problème si j'allais perdre
ma tour
ces cinq pour eux aussi c'est pas si
grave quoi mais en fait juste j'ai envie
de frimer en fait tu aurais pu reprendre
et aurait eu tant de bouger car alliés
devaient encaisser le fouet puis d'être
dans la diagonale avec la dame et je
serai en fait en terme de points c'était
bien pour moi mais mon but ce n'est pas
de marquer des points
enfin je crois qu'on vient phase où
j'avais gardé ma position ne pas
affaiblir de pahé changer de pièce papa
me retrouve en activité numérique pour
qu'à un moment les mecs décide de se
dire tiens il ya eu des faits de jeu
l'attaqué de ce matin
qui te dit vin et émile tué 1766 tu as
besoin de conseils
développe des pièces francs le centre
vérifier avant chaque coup que tu ne
l'ès pas de pièces emprise les faux
échec
bon déjà le rouge il peut il peut aller
pour faire un pion tout au bout de la
gérer avec son fouquet celle du système
de l'andrh mais ils le voient pas tu
penses bah je passe à lui de jouer il
fait comme hymne d'où il prend une chose
ça je suis très content mais c'est très
mal joué dans un mois qu'il une idée
mais je suis hyper réalistes les mecs
perdre des traces vous fait des pièces
ils s'affaiblissent l'un à l'autre non
mais je crois que tu et rouge est très
mauvaise il était juste donné son
scooter avec soin mais le problème c'est
que je pouvais pas le prendre le jaune
qu'elle allait me prendre le truc en
inde
sheva en fait c'est enfin moi je dis un
truc par rapport à ces échecs 1,4 à
prêcher pas dans chat on dira ce qu'on
en pense mais moi je pense que faire des
parties avec des mecs minimum 2006 d'un
jeu par là ça pourrait être plus sympas
en fait parce que du foot du coup enfin
tu vois ce que je veux dire enfin pour
nous en tout cas fière d'avoir des mecs
d'un même niveau échec c'est plus coup
puisque du coup tu peux penser et tu as
diarra 6 bandes alors que la bombe
dan bull s'est donc oui mais en fait
c'est hyper important c'est daniel il
m'a dit m'a dit pareil quoi très
important de faire fi enquête au direct
et rauque et quand il m'a dit ce très
important à ce jeu dérivé de la comédie
la santé il m'a dit peut-être faut
mettre le x 6 points quoi il m'a dit la
tour beaucoup moins forte que le fou il
comprend pas quoi ou alors la tour à
quatre points mais bon il comprend pas à
quoi il y le fou peut attaquer deux
joueurs en même temps la maison ne peut
pas il faut bourrer assidus plus ou
moins tu peux mais bon même est beaucoup
plus dur il m'a dit bishop matchs seront
garés lane chef mais c'est lui qui fait
l'âme c'est lui qui fixe les règles
exactement c'est fantastique que l'on
connaît mais qui fait les règles bien
devrait l'appeler c'est bon il est la
nuit des toits de jeu j'ai trois coups
j'ai deux s'en [ __ ] des buts
non mais il a même écrit un article pour
expliquer comment très bon il faut
attaquer le mac à ta gauche toujours
tout en un
bah moi je pense que ma cote à droite
que tu dois toc et non oui il faut
arrimer 80 et faire attention mais quand
à gauche c'est le plus dangereux pour
toi en fait le mec
on boycottera van damme sirou je vais
changer d'amis qui échangent se sera
opération nul pour chacun mais il fuit
ça c'est bien c'est une bonne nouvelle
sa fuite
mais du coup les ducs en fait pourquoi
tout le monde s'est barré du centre en
fait je comprends pas ce qui se passe
chez ba ba je vais continuer à avancer
mon ami tu les as effrayer un jeu comme
en fait non mais je crois avoir fait tu
étais pas du tout au centre et les mecs
se sont barrés en fait je comprends pas
ce qui se passe en fait non mer rouge
j'ai peut-être à les conserver une firme
mal donc quoi les mecs à sa droite fab
bah ouais mais bon ils affrontent ieto
il est bien défendu
non mais ils demandent pour quelle
raison tu peux pas savoir états d'âme
sur h6 suis défoncé droits et devoirs
aussi j'ai remarqué c'est quand tu
décides de dater un mec
en fait tu chéris forcément du matériel
dans ton attaque et beaucoup de temps et
pendant ce temps il peut se passer
d'autres choses mais en fait je préfère
juste ne pas mater un mec moi je m'en
fous j'essaie de dans une bonne position
globale et un jour on verra ce qui se
passe plus tard quoi bon je me cassais
avec madame
alors pourquoi les mecs à ta droite dire
que la cij attaqué jaune en fait je suis
une menace jaune ya rouge qui va jouer
entre temps il ya bleus qui va jouer
entre temps et du coup on peut
facilement être à trois contre un moment
djar djar juif est un échec rouge le rec
une dame blu-ray qu'une tour il par
l'échec si vous qu adam se bouffent la
tour ça pèse un truc comme ça qui se
passe par exemple mais c'est plutôt en
fin de partie la peau il se passe pas
grand chose
non mais je te dis c'est très beau but
ce n'est pas retenue se passerait c'est
absolument fantastique
mais est ce que ça joue bien en fait
ouais c'est un super jones et passerez
un bon bastille échanges cavaliers je
peux pas tout interdire non plus je la
remets ça ici voilà pourquoi tu as une
thalheim en arrière comme ça j'ai envie
de faire caillage 5 est aussi bleu je
pensais qu'ils allaient pousser le cuir
au centre ne gagna temps sur la dame est
vrai pas me prendre une double attaque
pendant que bloom face ça que je ne me
fasse autre chose
ça veut dire le dernier coup qui l'a
joué leurs attaques et madame à l'état
et si bleu si jonas moi vous êtes
français 6 ça allait trop loin
il ya un chat pour faire des alliances
hui à non non mais tu peux
éventuellement ouais j'ai pas il ya
carmen qui dit que bon ben voilà
qu'enfin le lit le cavalier bleu
ah c'est pas mal fait en fait son
cavalier cloud et oui c'est pour ça que
jamais les avants photo 2 ouais mais tu
peux pas y aller en force genre tu
sacrifies sur j'essaie tu fais dame g5
et y va vraiment force à bloc notes ans
déjà j'ai un truc à éviter là bas ce
condo jeunes y attaquer c'est pas mal ça
trouve la tour quand même c'est
d'apprendre de la tour studio qu'est-ce
qu'on attend et rendant des sciences et
partout où je prends trois points qu'est
ce que ça lui fait une dame
il prône la tour et il peut continuer à
me reprendre le pion h ou du fou je me
pète et monsanto balaté mal en fait ce
que tu es obligé quand même de prendre
le fou dans ces cinq points
ouais mais du coup le jeune ils sont
enfin là du plus ça tourne mal parce que
l'aij soit 1,3 comtois but de mettre le
jeu collectif comme toi car notre côté
car oui et en plus le cavalier protège
pas le pion h5 à me protège que du coup
s'il fait tout reprend il va prendre
avec la moelle à sa tête ce coup là il
protège championnat 5 en fait donc en
jaune va te faire [ __ ] en bessin qu'il
pourra pas prendre 5 qui sera défendue
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup qu'est
ce qu'il faut je comprends rien
mais ton roi est faible mais de façon
jaune il va tenter cette option non jeu
comment va chez vauréens des sports a
manqué ce pas un mal dommage il n'en a
encaissé ce qu'on ne voulait pas voir
bon on a été hyper mal face à roanne
c'est mon pion central vraiment s'en
[ __ ] sur écoute on va ramener fou non
je peux pas ils se mettent la main sur
des clous âge mais il sera quand on fait
au final bah rien ni de love on est mal
moi je suis d'aucune aide
je comprends rien la revue science est
impossible de céder à ses joueurs or
voilà que bleu et un peu taquiné jaune
mais c'est pour ça en fait j'aime pas
concéder conflit j'aurais peut-être pas
dû aller même choqué h ce matin place
des cures entre en guerre tu vois tu il
ya des fonds de partout
les cobras en fait à 3 komodo autour de
toi et va en gros c'est ça sent la et
hop une morsure que c'est fini mais
c'est horrible à un comores la mort avec
le commodo en jeu la rôtisserie que joe
d'aucune 22 secondes il ya tout moment
on peut semer traitement l'otan et ça ça
fausse trop le jeu j'aime pas le fait
que les joies ils peuvent être des puces
est déconnecté j'interdirais en fait
moitié banni du site ouais enfin je
pense qu'ils n'auraient pas à faire un
genre tu est déconnecté de trois fois et
enfin tu finis pas les parties ou non tu
devrais fin tu d'où une dame bleus qui
arrive
ouais mais en fait le truc c'est qu'il
sait ici centre protège quoi bâtissant
que moi j'ai pas trop envie de prendre
ma part de madame et que d'autres
l'autre idiot de jaune non plus mais
j'ai quand même prendre un tu as perdu
une dame
ben écoute lui va mais bon tant pis tant
mieux pour lui
je suis dit ça ferait pas de truc je
voulais aussi ouvrir la colonne pour que
rouge elle prend de la tour en main mais
bon au je crois qu'ils n'essaient de
m'attaquer mois plus tôt justin c'est
chaud la moria un coup j'ai pas envie de
faire on va y aller c'est pousser le
pion ça m'intéresse pas trop il ya ton
foot il ya emprise aussi inquiet de 7e
mais je sais je veux plus me kiejman
york en tête et par h5
je pense que c'est très très mal
voilà mal joué mais bon il va te prendre
il va te prendre ton fou un an je vois
aussi bleu prend aux forces fonctions
centrales dont blush parce qu'ils
parlent ils parlent opposé à m6 est
attaqué par le cuir jaune comme ça moi
les rouges faits de menaces sur joue sur
bleu celui qui est des bébés si saleh
sait que les rouges rouges logiquement
il a plutôt peur de toi en fait oui il
fantasme c'est complètement débile et va
te faire mater ouais mais ce que j'ai
envie de films pièces pour le matin non
mais ok mais a minima tu peux prendre
son pion rouge déjà non annonçant votre
sanction allant dans le sens ça si ce
soit va super ça commence à clasher
contre jaune et bleu il laisse sa dame
bizarre mais je crois qu'il a fait un
coup de froid qu'à chaud gars qui met du
coup c'est à john de jouer ça je ne
viens pas de pousser son action cbh le
club c'est son vrai j'ai un âge si ça va
on a six mois je peux pas où tu te rates
hockey de partout et je pense pas tu
peux en profitèrent moi je suis un petit
coup comme ça sent pas je vais faire du
fer du khalife six échecs
toi tu va tirer les marrons du feu leur
vous avant - c'est génial de vieilles
dames qui va dégager
comment tu as réussi à te sortir de ce
conflit est un génie
les jaunes va prendre injustice là bas
si francis était ado bas cela très
intéressant d'apprendre ce pion
symptômes comme saint poix qu'est ce que
ça et il attaque bleu donc dire qu'en
fait on peut tous attaqué bleus comme
des oufs mais je crois que en fait j'ai
pas si t'as intérêt à attaquer rouge ou
bon écoute on va y aller comme aux
échecs normes
donc je peux à faire puis on prend non
je pousse ses pions et l'autre est la
deuxième dame entre 6h et vivre comme il
a pas pris quoi jean oui mais si vous y
allez va de nouveau être en échec
découvert le jour est au bout je serre
cavalier 5
peut-être qu'il y arrive ça ne s'est pas
à l'origine exacte en gros ce que je
vais faire mais en fait c'est
fantastique et jaune prend la tour là au
double fantastique bergénias je fais ça
je me sens yesha qui va retourner là bas
j'ai fait recaler f6 puis on prend force
et puis on prend matin en fait c'est
fantastique parce que du coup il n'a pas
il n'a pas vu la tour du journal vatan
il peut modeler pour monter le roi font
quoi on arrive à monter le roi je pense
mais déjà formaté au centre mais
auxquels s'ajoutent pas si mal dans
cette partie ouais mais il faut pas
qu'il était le seul à pouvoir tirer les
marrons du feu
de quel feu du mat du roi ouais bah non
je sens le problème c'est que des fois
il ya des milliers d opportuniste re le
vocal je suis assez bien placé avec mes
deux câbles qui avait traîné un peu tout
le monde autour maman
hier je mate forcé à 1 2 3 ou plus d'un
jour n'est plus là donc on va contrer
votre à de nouvelles attaques de l'autre
côté quoi en fait tout l'enjeu sera le
roi rapidement battant ou alors
j'attaque rouge
non non non on attaque par le temps
n'est plus aux bleus regrettant qu'ils
attaquent
je m'attends de et bleu 1 il est longue
le tanger du continent blanc et rouge
vont avoir beau ce qu'il fait mais rouge
ah oui parce qu'il peut pas rentrer le
roi maintenant ah oui ça va bien jouer
facile mais non pas toi qui es et vire
au mieux et tant que je contrôle un peu
ce que fait bleus par rapport aux voies
alors le skiff elle qui fait rien il ne
va pas attaquer droit dont tu peux
continuer à jouer pour le match malgré
je pense je pense pas que bleu et puis
ce matin puisque tu es mieux là ok
j'aime attendre un prochain
est-ce que bleu peu c'est de l'attaqué
le roi jaune je crois pas trop aux
menaces il arrive avant toi en fait
ouais bah écoute ça devient non mais
attends enfin tu peux pas j'ai loupé
cette idée là c'est joli prendre trois
points mais bon s'il est rouge en vie il
faut bien manger les restes côté tu peux
au prix d'une dame enfin protéger quoi
tu peux mettre ta d'amoureux aussi
suivre avec elle que je mate l'autre et
tu laisses d'autres envies et puisque
l'eau tu peux aussi lui gratter des
pièces tu peux aussi lui faire un échec
tu prends la dame et où je sais pas en
fait je m'attends à ce que d'un v6 d'un
autre côté j'ai vu que trois secondes
que j'ai accéléré la cadence donc aux
échecs normand own you honte à 2 pour la
luge et une pièce de moins d'une pièce
de moins et un pur une pièce un pion
ok mais bon je m'y colle aux échecs on
va dire des choses comme ça on s'en fout
bon ok je pense qu'il va il va sacrifier
ses chevaux c'est hyper compliqué comme
je suis en sueur à mai au kenya ds de
partout et pierre musset pièces des
pièces grise bloquent le passage
ouais c'est fantastique alors les
matraques et ça te moquer des gens
fantastiques sétif bah je trouve que
c'est encore plus débile que la greffe
je pense que ça va beaucoup plus loin
que le reste en fait face à ce que j'ai
l'air d'un idiot si c'est encore plus
profond dans le mec il est une cible
[Musique]
maigrissez sur l'it chasse pas du tout
113 points quand même très intéressant
comme six points comme sont des modes de
jeu qu'il se passe au lieu de chasser
les meilleurs modes de jeu des recettes
c'est le meilleur truc en fait nous
jusqu'à 4 way fantastique un mode de jeu
elle y tient sans sueur de ne pas avoir
laissé chaque avec goethe en caisse ou
je te pousse je pense aussi tu peux
abandonner à tout moment et ça donne 20
points à l'adversaire c'est un truc que
j'ai vu à quel adversaire
enfin ça donne 20 points son petit
abandonne en fait ça donne ton roi
ah oui ça en fait dès que tu as besoin
de plus c'est bon à whistler klink les
moulinois également touché quelque part
bon écoute je sais pas je la dame
n'importe où il reste de ce qu'on a fait
à chaque début de soirée est ce qu'on
pense faire des petits chardy streaming
en train de bosser dessus
en fait ouais je sais pas assez chaud là
tu calcules ya trop de pièces quoi la
pietà des trucs grille au mieux les
bobines dame qu'est ce que c'est que ce
coût le coup tu te prends en plus il
peut les prendre sadaada bas mais ça je
prends de saddam à 10 points
la fin latta +12 serre que tu es plus
très loin du clem de wing si tu prends
saddam et que tu abandonnes arrive et ça
j'ai appris ça va mais c'est une chose
mais jusqu'en mai tu peux prendre la
lame abandonné au monde tu prends tu
aimes le wind je pense non c'est que tu
peux qu abandonner à ton tour non mais
là tu étais tu sais tu es en train de
prendre le dessus et se moquent ils
m'attaquent le staff ou bien défendu bah
peu plus tôt on nous a menti ajoutant
que ça c'est n'importe quoi ce
fantastique c'est génial on doit toucher
aux seconds de la russie ne sont plus
des villes que ce que tout ce qu'on a
fait avant en fait en fait je pensais tu
vois je pense toujours non on a fait des
trucs les plus débiles possible et il a
toujours un nouveau ce que je suis et ce
comme c'est comme au niveau de l'epic
quoi tu fais toujours un truc épuisé
picard nos trucs et là quand même c'est
quand même plus débile que ce qu'on a pu
faire avant tout mon corps indom
d'invoquer la taille vraiment en train
de prendre le dessus
les dix hommes de partout et ils
échangent non je t'échange et eric si on
met je peux prendre ça à toujours en
plus tu vas faire encore des bulldogs
c'était une force d'âme
alors oui c'est vrai boom vous
tu veux jouer toit où j'ai eu des ennuis
continuent pour tout changer très haut
niveau moi je rentre dans le football en
direct
ça recommence gilet jaune car en sus
chat nous disent quoi il demande si on
va suivre le tournoi de majorque
ah oui on va mais en fait je pense qu'on
est les seuls à 6 les tours de haut
niveau en depuis très longtemps
en france personne d'autre qui le fait
en fait pas avant qu'on soit là il ya
personne qui le faisait on est là bas on
le fait et puis quand on partira
d'ailleurs ça n'aura plus rien le désert
quoi mais c'est vrai en plus votre carte
tu veux empêcher rouge de faire une dame
où ce que quelqu'un de faire un truc
intelligent dans cette partie on sait
pas et c'est complètement génial car en
fait tu veux absolument québec se tape
entre lacanau 5 avec les bleus avec les
verts comme ça tu le bloc bon mais je te
prendrais pas je voyais que je m'en fous
je me prendre le truc non non aux
minarets tout va pour m'amener continue
dans ce sens sur un chemin qui bluffera
m dames aussi au mieux il peut pas faire
dame rouge voilà il est défendu auprès
de verre avec ses sons fut son cavalier
il finalement il a fait une protection
évolution rouges veulent mettre un peu
au ps bart veille et très peu de très
près du rouge et or la france est assez
rare en jeu mais rouge et coton fut en
fait aux jo j'ai dcid perception là mais
rouge en fait s'il est en grand danger
parce qu'il ya bleus qui l'attaquent
déjà et en plus bleu il fait une double
attaque qui peut encaisser ses fonctions
mais il va pas vouloir que flynn dame
il va alors qu'ils pourraient six de ses
films dame mais il fera le plein et
pourquoi enfin il prend le pion l'autre
le prend il en est à cinq points il à la
tour qui rentre sur sur les sols il va
se dire ouais mais bon heureusement une
dame quoi encaisser 5 point et tu
rentres cheveux courts en maintenant ses
protégés c'est fini que le pion rouge
est protégé par part vers les verts peut
prendre
le barça pour 2,6 et les verts s'y prend
il met en pls il est venu en sueur
non mais ok mais enfin faut se taper un
peu dessus l'amérique bulldogs à mais
c'est génial messi vert prend en fait il
va être super match des bleus c'est quoi
ce coup double à temps il fut comble
pour qu'il a reculé saddam comme un
idiot en attaque confions 11h comprendre
mais bon c'est de la merde socotram
détroit nathan est ce que je vais
reprendre mes verres que prendre du
cavalier en fait je vends beaucoup lourd
vote avant le coeur ouvert un peu là se
dit bon bah non oui mais en fait si près
du cavalier voulait peut-être promis
voilà c'est fait faire se fait défoncer
dans tous les sens là je peux faire quoi
j'en profite sur et voici que je
pourrais m'en [ __ ] complètement
je n'attaque personne moi je continue la
stratégie de jénine je prends le sentent
non mais en fait vers il en train de se
faire dépecer quoi un registre son idée
de dames cinglé bleus de l'attaqué rouge
mais en fait rouge à une lampe et n est
ce pas ce qui m'a moi je prendrais
l'attaqué verts eelv où les fameux
collision avec bleu mais en fait c'est
débile il pouvait prendre effet si ces
menaces et madame prend à chute ce que
l'hôte et le sombre écoute moi je suis
bien heureux du torrent la partie aurait
dit stop tous dessus et moi je peux
faire à toute méthode ruiz tranquille
dans mon coin de ma évasif 1 l'aca peut
être choisies rouge m'échauffe toi comme
prend un f6 tu m'as as m'attendre j'ai
envie que ça parte en envoyer ton pote
way maintenant il défend sa superbe mais
franchement très mal joué de la part de
rougeole fallait aller fallait si on
prend un verre et puis enfin une paire d
as mais plus aussi en fait ils allaient
attaquer là bas alors qu'il pouvait
faire une coalition dézinguer lueur bien
qu'il ya des côtés autour de nevers est
tout à fait c'est horrible je suis très
content je suis très content avec 69
j'ai fait une sorte de pyramide
vous me faites aux attaques et adam g
fut un échec si tu fais chaque île
éthique hautement dans la mare rouge
lancé une série d'attaqués rechute est
magnifique le début de la partie 1
[Musique]
c'était génial fâchez pas c'était trop
épique et c'est que ce coup je réfléchis
bonfoh a choisi quatre femmes ont pu en
âge de là bas bonjour assez fantastique
il ya rouge écrit mme buchanan quoi il
pas pétanque c'est fantastique rouge de
jeanne mas pignou cet accablement
il est très énervé je te dis ils sont
compliqués à tour en fait il ne joue
plus la partie assez génial regarde ma
mère' gars il va il se fait défoncer un
petit point mais bon du coup il me
regarde mais y avait il ya verts qui va
lui en tisser sa tour regard vers boom
ouais bah ou pas les rouges il enterrait
ce cas au pérou qui veut attaquer tout
le monde entier contre bleu rouge c'est
tout là ils attaquent et va bien fantasy
samedi pour ça de l'autre faudra que
c'est une super idée de ne jamais être
en guerre locaux enfin saint-girons
points mais après tu as des âmes cga ce
qu'en fait ils auraient pu agir elle
aurait pu être très énervé de base et
isole vin rouge il aurait pu défoncé
vert est en fait du coup mais en fait
j'ai pas est-ce qu'il va prendre le cas
mal il est complètement taré où il va
faire un truc tu aurais fait il peut
abandonner en fait maintenant trente
cavaliers verdien par un coin tant qu
état d'âme les mecs se chauffe c'est
génial chance que tu tire les marrons du
feu
t'es tu peux faire un saut dames vicieux
pour lui faire dame des sept matches
genre tu veux ça peut passer du temps
avec les français ce qui va lui arriver
chanceux
la dame de bleu la lanterne way we le
bleu bleu je pense qu'il fait d'amd
s'est tu peux le maté femme m'a dit
prends ça donne c'est hyper messieurs
c'est génial ouais c'est super bien
parti la face aux bleus il défend attend
vélo je veux faire mater qui prend ses
stats le rouge est fantastique
est-ce que les points rouges ou bar à
vous je suis t'en fiches non tu vas
larrazet pas d'ailleurs je devrais aller
déjà pour le matériel roulant
tu devrais peut-être attaque et ça tout
rond rouge passe comme ça il va faire
maths tuant quelle sera sa tour par
échec
ouais mais en fait faut pas que vers
s'en mêle effacé chacun rouge à messi
s'il fait chacun rouge soit tu prends ça
coûte et tue le match c'est génial
sylvère fait échec c'est fini
sylvère fait chaque en f3 ou je sais pas
sur quelles cases c'est fini maintenant
que je peux faire échec à 20h mais aussi
avec mon pion au foyer chez cailler
découverte et kung fu c'est génial
notes partout là c'est le bordel c'est
fantastique
en tout cas plus a pris cher finalement
non mais c'est bizarre ce que de bas
sévère qui devait se faire défoncer les
verts il a bien ces scénarios de génie
tu france à tours au prochain tu mates
bleus peut-être dans mes bleus va jouer
entre temps en fait ouais il va bouger
sa tour des huit oui mais bon vin rouge
nous allons vers mon la tour de rouge
vous jeudi m tl s
vas-y prend franchement mêlant fait
laisse dans le sable à main sable mais
du coup bleus il peut s'en prendre à la
tour de rouge c'est génial et la
maintenance à cinq points en six matches
joués ce que j'ai fait pourquoi en fait
ah non ça en fait ok mais masisi rouges
jouent en premier vers aurait il perdu
la vie
nous aimons c'est la bonne aitor et
insultes non qu'il veut faire une
alliance qui est rouge de faire une
alliance avec bleu maintenant parce
qu'ils que sinon vert vert va gagner moi
qui suis pas qu'on lui prépare t il avec
mon cheval de bataille pas grand-chose à
ok c'est parce qu'il double échec et mat
ok enfin allianz à la raison mais
pourquoi tu vas pas maté faut que tu
mates rouge un ouais moi c'est
fantastique comme parti
mais tu peux peut-être amené ton
cavalerie en attaque et tout un c'est
chaud regardez allez quoi faire des
dames au centre et où donc ce passif est
rouge on laisse en vie pour ça non mais
là je pense que c'est toi qui tire les
marrons du feu non non je pense je suis
de jouer que 15 dames contre il ya une
dame qui va arriver
goutrens moustiques mais en fait tu pas
sûr qu'il faille mater rouge direct est
il faut raser un un rsa on va raser ou
jaune le survivant un peu si l'outil
rouge peut être chiant pour l'autre
c'est bien ça j'allais faire notre dame
là bas je peux encore comment je me
trouve des personnes non puis c'est
génial parce que du coup ton roi il peut
plus du tout à être attaqué je suis en
quoi le rouge est très énervé après vers
maintenant ouais parce que vers elle et
lui prendre de but c'est un truc aussi
en fait il ya le fou de verre emprise
totale en fait une femme découverte où
on n'est pas de décodeur sa part belle
en fait même si je ne dois plus faite
aux repentis sache qu'on a besoin de
points barret tu reprends du pion turf
est en retard white tu t'en fiches non
tu prends une tour assez génial juste
frottait est bon il peut prendre de six
à cinq ans
fantastique bref pas qu'ils prennent
trop de points mais bon tu contrôles à
il joue pour le maintien
bon écoute moi c'est amener un peu tu
peux pas aller mater vert en fait mais
tu vas prendre l'air avec des dames en
fait genre le mettre en échec et le
défoncer on aperçoit un rouge les chocs
c'est bien comme ça tu peux mettre le
vert en échec sans arrêt là deux fois
d'affilée je voulais venir leur chair de
seconde puisqu'en fait ce qu'il sait sur
rabelais de tours de verre en fait fi du
mat
maintenant les embarrasse victoire
pendant qu'elle soit on encaisse des
points quand même fantastique gravats
par jason behr pas encore où j'ai trop
de points mais ça va aller au jura 52
nous on a 36 56 à la fin sous allait
abandonner le c'est un rouge
heureusement que rouge a pas le temps de
temps je peux te donner notamment aux
jeux où je ramène gens fourbes ramène
ton fou pour être une pâte on fout
j'aurais amené le fou encore en attaque
mais tu as le matin avec le four
imprévus c'est matt damon v8 est fou
machin maths ou avec la dame tu mates
avec n'importe quoi à il ce barrage
avait pas vu beaucoup tronqué c'est un
truc markets l'euro à peut-être n'a
jamais dit qu'on a toutes les pièces
encore en vie auront la partie parfaite
comme on a envie d'en jouer ça tout le
temps d'armer à ses filles enfin gère le
mec à 40 da mais j'ai vu de cavalli mais
de fou mais deux tours 1 2 3 4 5 6 pions
et ok juste un pion qui a péri dans
toute la partie
et un qui sont souvent dame ce panache
c'est très content de ma performance au
title fusée et donc c'est pas une halte
à de chasse c'est un mec l'oeuf connaît
un américain et ce serait très contente
pas fou le pour toi mais bon elle a bien
tourné
c'est le bon scénario qui s'est passé ça
aurait pu mal tourner bah ouais mais tu
es vraiment bon en fait
ben alors partie jeter quoi de mon père
n'est ce pas non rien pas de première
partie s'il est pas eu la déconnexion
balles et j'étais dégoûté faisant
vaciller amex et des connecteurs des
buts et 20 points pour les gars et après
je vois 2 contre 1,20 c'était la totale
boker essaie de faire trois ou quatre
échecs mais ce jour que d'autres sais
pas comment on peut s'organiser ce que
c'est complètement aléatoire ce serait
marrant alors que demandé de programmer
un truc à lui sont signalés super fort
car fait une dernière était en sueur
mais en fait c'est un truc pareil qui
possible parce que c'est tu peux jouer
par équipes
bahia et mode single et mode par équipes
à tête là deux congos et comme ou catch
serait peut-être essayer ça non
tellement heureux de jouer à ça mais
qu'ai je connais pas le truc en équipe
de stars ce genre t'es jaunes et verts
contre les deux autres bon ça marche je
fais new game et tu as que j'essaye
attends je suis comme celle new game
j'avais d'ailleurs pas fait les teams
soit free for all team et c'est quoi ah
[ __ ] mais je peux de choisir a way
vient j'en ai vu m'a dit comment ça
s'écrit pas de stream m'est avis qu'ils
aident elles et c'est quoi le trévignon
cette réunion du 6 ya pas de trait
d'union sur chelsea et jamy triomphe sur
dix seraient en fait notre fan d'ici aux
arts comment ça je suis là attends je
vais essayer de trouver non mais attends
je te trouve new game team's ouais ok
c'est bon on va les mettre ensuite en
être complètement démission à faire
faire une vidéo je pense est un des deux
maintiens fida mayer lui dégage ça ne
sert à rien c'est débile ça c'est dit ou
tu es en jaune bon alors bon rythme tout
va bien mais là c'est bon on s'en prend
à un bleu ou à voir rouge
voilà non mais rouge c'est moi avons
fait b3 l'a fait par exemple au maître
ils font diagonale
ça va chier il vaut mieux à 8 au dessus
peut il prendre le sentons comme moi je
fais des fonds de kétou pas de faire des
prophéties quand même mais bon non pas
60 alors plus et qui va ce dédale attend
si je fais shaqab le lâcher au clash et
xhaka vers hockey à temps mais un truc
fantastique tu vas voir je le fous des
cette avance est génial j'ai fait
recaler fit cavalier h5 fera couler cet
échec il va interposés enfin le temps
joue au centre des contents
fantastique qui ne voit pas venir et
comprendre
gfr kabila j'ai compris chaque couche
projet cet été les fics en toi tu
pousses champions voilà il faut qu'il
soit bon il faut qu'il évite la viennale
sinon bon sinon j'ai juste envie d'avoir
ce cas là il peut plus pousser assez
génial ils ont peur de ça alors je le
mets là où je me lave à oui mais il ya
bleus qui peut me prendre mon fou nature
adam prend alain coulon le temps aller
aux attentes
ok g7 ne le rend fou un peu ils feront
fouet c'est la merde ouais bah non c'est
super chiant de voir le talent se
marient ou pas à la stratégie qui est
tombé à l'eau mais ça je fonderai
beissat chez lui du qooq
ok j'ai arrêté d'y jouer des 3,3 en fait
devant mont royal progressera une sorte
de coup du berger des échecs à 4 mai
dans le côté madame sera super bien
placés en séries feuilletons et moi
j'irai lui prendre son temps c'est fait
il est sa tour du coup ses hôtes qui va
être engagée tant sur ses commandes et
ville c'est génial ça c'est génial
parties peuvent ils encore dans notre
monde équipé tout c'est génial prévu la
planète ils sont sûrs bana photo n'a pas
compris pas vous déployez son parti va
donner
blocage partiel qu'on veut pour rejouer
c'est tout ce que l'oeil du cyclone phet
mon lit moi aussi j'ai plaît laissez pas
ces accords c'est le meilleur jeu du
monde trajet du convoi arrive pas je le
mette du berger attendu tim reif habibi
s'acquitte jouer la merde les suppliques
toile jeu mais sinon je fais hadjadj est
sécurisé alors je peux rizaï né le match
en équipe quoi mais bon le truc c'est
qu'en fait il faut jouer ensemble justin
perriot je p 17 bon écoute on va les
noms mais c'est génial ce mode de jeu
fâchez pas jolie leçon la ddjs et très
très bien joué on y tient très très
intéressant et surtout je le mène
l'adresse dans le tchad tient bruxelles
gens l'aimaient qui met en pls quoi ces
jeux
en fait ces mêmes patches à ce point
comme quoi chez ce point comme cela je
for players soit je sais pas mais c'est
le jeu de l'année toutes plus
intéressantes les échecs c'est au coût
de 25 à 30
oui c'est beaucoup plus intéressant en
faites pas je pense que ce jeu est
complètement au dessus de tout j'arrive
pas à trouver ta partie mais on se parle
c'est un truc en équipe joe camec à très
bon d'ajouter 1122 gros chasse à
l'affairé foyer ils ont rien compris à
ce qui leur arrive et avec pt deepwater
horizon de partout y compris comment ça
j'ai perdu mais je joue avec un génie
love machine f3b 3 il est notre faire
bouffer un fou j'ai devoir jouer tout
seul contre toute la clique bas mais
c'est un des meilleurs modes de jeu
enfin j ai jamais vu un truc aussi bien
de ma vie enfin je ne sais pas peut-être
que les mecs sont au courant qu'on joue
le titre ou peut-être que vous verrez
bleus peut se manger des pièces entre
lens et pas mais tu marques des fonds
mais du coup l'objectif c'est quoi ces
de maths essaie de mettre des points je
comprends rêve bas maths c'est fini
c'est k o et puis les points bas à youri
dernier a forcément match à ibach matin
j'en peux plus de ce partenaire bon je
crois je vais reese a nié puis et puis
voilà que j'aurais que avec toi mode
équipe d'un menu pour ses équipes de
haut niveau mais je pense qu'on peut
complètement devenir meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux enfin si on s'y met bien ça va
être fantastique enfin va plus que
commenter des partis comme salaire
maintenant des commentaires partisans
mais ce serait génial de faire un speech
est championship de sept de ses 17
idiotie fait imagine le trouver dans ce
cas l'équipe française on vous défonce
et mais en fait c'est ça en fait les
l'ailé dès qu'on s'appelle les vrais
noms mais le 10 sport bah oui c'est
beaucoup plus ça en fait beaucoup plus
drôle ça séduit ce pas en fait ça c'est
ça c'est pour être beaucoup plus
médiatique que les échecs normand fait
pas beaucoup plus intéressant en fait
mais attends je remets en équipe
notre g des flèches là c'est quoi ben
j'ai pas à terre j'ai fait je fais toi
qui lis des flèches sur mon truc non moi
j'ai des flèches qui se dessine après je
vais pas trouver j'ai fait charger fabi
je ne trouve pas à moi aussi je fais des
flèches j'espère défaite j'arrive sur
les six iep alpha vivier été bien fait
tt famille ben j'ai payé à l'usiné
gamecube une manette est en train de
jouer bah oui c'est ça mais je viens de
finir en fait on en fait une après mon
fils a pu ne pas faire damas ce jeu des
cieux j'ai dû mettre un tour sur les
huitièmes ranger il est soit huit
éléments restent toujours un pion c'est
beaucoup j'en ai marre rizani on va
jouer ensemble je peux qu abandonner à
mon tour voilà
donc même des rouges rouges décidé de
m'attaquer dont procopio la stratégie la
stratégie la partie précédente a été
juste magique à temps exit new game du
salon en équipe allait donc je les
accepte
[Musique]
ok je suis un bon bah oui je serai petit
yacht est simple soit on fait pas on
fait pas de bab en fait donc main mais
je prends le centre calme parce que bien
que quelqu'un allait prendre le sens de
notre équipe bon motta son attachement
au groupe la stratégie et s'est même
fait des 5
il est maintenant trois coups quoi ne
sais pas pourquoi peut-être le faire une
stratégie mais je n'ai pas pu dormir en
cause mais là du coup on fait faire des
échanges c'est pas si grave
ouais en fait jason qu'il faut être à
deux sur un an fait se déchaîner sur un
note aaa l'auteur a mis l'algérie qui
englobe six ans fait ok ok t'inquiète
pas mais j'ai une idée je peux faire
tout projet 7 et toi tu lui feras un
coût des chèques ne pourra pas me
prendre et je pense à lui défoncer sa
position ouais je vais tenir en échec en
temps mais je pense g7
vas-y vas-y d'ailleurs il va jouer un
truc et tu fais food étonné ouais il en
sueur qui ne prendra pas le fou c'est
génial ouais mais là on compte pas les
ponts en fait il n'y a pas de point la
fosse en prendre un mec on prend la tour
quand même ok donc un truc important
c'est de ne pas pouvoir se faire
attaquer droit en enfer qu'est ce que
c'est que ça la chambre basse et 22e et
pièce qui met échec je comprends mais là
je veux juste reprendre normalement juge
réfléchi puisque je peux mettre bleus en
échec si jamais je vends parce que je te
rends pas bon je continue à développer
j'avance un pion
non en fait c'est hyper dangereux comme
des attaques directes très rapide mais
en fait je pense que bleu et comprend
pas non plus que vers veut faire j'ai
peu une fois tenté de jouer cavalier
quoi ah ouais ben ali par française 6 à
la rencontre à l'eau lourde défaite à
[ __ ] ils sont issus adam est protégé
et puis c'était joli ça ouais c'est
nouveau rush mode attaque on va
progresser je t'invite vas-y là c'est
bon ok ok pas de microsoft ont trait aux
fennecs en fait faut toujours pouvoir
mettre un mec en échec
ouais je pense faut toujours avoir une
possibilité de mettre un adversaire en
échec pour si jamais non je suis vert
berlin n'est pas ensemble
je suis jeune mais je convaincs fin
janvier ensemble bah non je ne m'écroule
l'homme était sur balles à toi tu es
vers toi moi je suis jaune rouge et
attaqué ses travaux mais attend les
secours ont arrêté sur coup je pense
badosa et comment savoir qui joue avec
qui attend je regarde les règles et avec
blue toi nous sommes là d'autres comme
moi la belote quand même bon soin ouais
ouais je vais avec bleu paris bloquée
c'est pas drôle
donc moi je faisais son partenaire
attention je me fais un schéma dalton
bell aimons ce qui est marrant c'est
discuter machin enfin baveux à mais en
fait on joue pas en équipe je pense non
ou si je commence demain
bah en même temps s'ils n'ont pas innové
sur son équipe maïs et sur les plaies
d'un modem on veut jouer en équipe on
voit équipe ne veut pas jouer ce nom je
pense à un bug en fait
ouais c'était pas mal comment ils nous
ont maté râler mais qu'il fallait enfin
sérieux c'était mal dommage on aurait su
français si l'on n'a pas compris mais
j'ai senti qu'il y avait un truc de
trafalgar fin j'ai senti qu'il fallait
faire française il ne savait pas
pourquoi enfin valait mieux pas le faire
pour comprendre en fait dans les bacs et
d'attaquer rouge quoi comment on fait
quoi tiens je pour le centre
le pauvre où je vole mon père est ce
parce qu'il fait a fait que l'ouverture
la directive aucune pièce contre angers
6 6 n'aura ainsi complètement donc quand
il a la chance que je puisse pas le
mater avec un cadre avec avec la cour
bon bah écoute épreuve 5 doit pas être
trop mauvais joue à trois contre un en
fait nous traçons dans une équipe
toujours on s'en fout quoi non en fait
j'ai envie de mettre le bleu en pls et
dale et attaque étoilé mec va rien
comprendre que ça allait mais tempéré ce
total mais bon ok je vais prendre ça
n'achetez pas assez dur d'organiser des
attaques de maths sans rigoler parce
qu'en fait tu as plein de pièces qu'elle
pensait je ne suis pas c'est hyper
compliqué comme je vous comprends rien
passe beaucoup trop compliqué
mais en fait il pas mais les pièces
elles bougent tellement différemment de
d'habitude
malouche pareil mais j'étais pas trop de
partout donc non mais j'ai après c'est
pas les mêmes patins en fait on n'a pas
l'habitude mais je pense à nous faire
régresser aux échecs on va de jouer à ça
serait génial j'ai pas mais c'est
complètement différent parce que tu peux
faire un combo si je peux jouer tu auras
tu peux jouer deux coups face
complètement différent en fait nathan
mais là le mec enfin le mec va se remet
à thé quoi faire
qu'est ce qu'il fout je suis sûr que si
on savait vraiment joué là je trouverai
un match facile de sa nature un prix
d'attaqué
gfr je viens un peu à la rescousse de
rouge quoi
attention je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait
il s'affaiblit encore à l'autre côté de
l'échiquier est assez compliqué ben
voilà on sent que rougier a pas
d'harmonie dans cette pièce ça peut être
compliqué j'arrive pas à le maté quoi
faire un jour j'arrive pas à trouver de
maths
tout ce que c'est que ça et c'est
complètement débile
c'est complètement con las qui injurie
jetons plus bas et enfin je comprends
pas ce qui fait parce que moi en fait ce
que je voulais faire de base c'était ça
et je voulais venir menacer des maths
quoi je comprends pas du tout l'idée du
coup en fait s'en fout et est beaucoup
mieux placé là bas c'est débile
les rougets contre qu'est ce que c'est
que son ami je crois que moi n'est pas
facile mais en fait c'est positif que
bleus n'est pas compris non plus en
reste non plus on ne m'a pas non plus
nous
tu protèges d'en prendre un petit effort
et je vais faire dame prendra mais dame
prend fou pardon et de mater grâce à la
dame de l'autre en fait j'ai pas si tu
as lu bon joueur bon ok
à
médard est bloqué si je fasse avec un
crétin pareil
non mais bon là en mains le champion du
monde
les choses à m'apprendre à l'oeuf ou pas
tiens si je la suis il m'aide à
l'emprise d'un rock et mad men je pense
qu'il faut juste pas pensé à lui balle
au début j'allais chez les juges aient
perdu qu'un set la yam attendent ainsi
si bleu de fées dam des mythes échec qui
fait tout reprendre dame prend et
c'était matin mais bon faut qu'ils le
voient ils sont complètement nul oh non
mais c'est pas possible
non non non pas la dame il avait pu en
prendre à vos pieds or vert et or mais
c'est pas possible on attend d'eux enfin
je ne peux plus jouer quoi non mais
c'est trop débile tu dois partir ça n'a
aucun intérêt
non mais alors remake absolument des
chiots riscle à ce qu'aurait fait d'un
projet 6 arrête mexicaine a vu qu'il
était sur les deux idiots de service
sera possible mais c'est ça le froid là
en fait c'est comme quand des fois je
joue à la belote avec des inconnus sur
internet et que j'étais fou de rage et
je vais tout casser quand la météo
tellement mal non mais qui avait un peu
plus quand j'ai même plus envie de jouer
enfin un bonbon plus le but sans vote on
va te laisser un pile ou face
on attend lequel est le plus mauvais de
tous les membres en de rouge mais
arcanes complètement nul j'essaie
d'aller mater quant à toi tout seul
bah oui enfin je sais pas comment fin tu
as français jugent la meilleure idée qu
équateur il a vidé la dame leïla a pu
prendre ce truc
ok mais je prends tu vois la flèche que
j'ai dessiné ou pas non non mais attends
les fans me médard david adam emprise
bic ou non les gens peuvent plus quand
il est complètement nul 1 me fait chacun
bah écoute
profitez-en et doivent en fait tu peux
d'indiquer les cotons parterre bondé
flèche sur l'échiquier mais j'ai encore
des flèches
[Musique]
tu l'as dit de prendre un homme non
alors il n'est pas utile à tout prix de
leurs bons ballons mais même quand on
n'a plus d'âme
si janot stick la chance c'est que
peut-être bleu et blanc quoi y'a quand
même neuf secondes c'est beaucoup donc
on peut espérer qu'ils tombent un peu
plus de bleu et blanc plus que 25
secondes
les bleus est très inquiet dès que
l'attaquant fait rattraper à la somme
exacte aura beaucoup de mal à mater de
façon baril je ne sais rien
beaucoup de pions c'était assez ridicule
à
bah
bon j'ai un partenaire de rêve voilà
j'ai tout raser la vie n'a plus rien les
bleus tiens je vais voir le mater en
fait tu as tu défends c'est à le croire
quand même à ce jeu tu te lèves et ça
c'est insupportable je pourrais pas
faire d'un format depuis défend comme ça
je montre aux gens là me qu'était une
fouille quoi ok mais qui fera pas le
défendre indéfiniment c'est pas possible
derrière ça tousse seconde quoi vous
calculez un match mettez pas trop débile
il fait d'amis six matches d'abondantes
il a bien compris je vais faire une
flèche à il a vu que j'ai fait la flèche
pourquoi ya pas mal parce que moi je
peux jouer ça au passage ben on ne prend
pas un messie puisque ça avant a joué
c'est de nouveau à rouge après à
d'autres que moi je défends pas des
cases maxime et la sarre où je jouais il
s'en sort commença à effet rouaroua
machin mais quel droit on est tous les
gars sont permanents et une casse qui
est pas prise dans les casiers 8e j'aime
à tour mois rim et à tourrettes compte
pas c'est fantastique vous ça tout au
plus bas mais ok mais la gamme le fini
bon je suis un peu loin pour venir le
défendre maintenant on va voir
charles schwab à votre chanson plus tôt
à métabief
c'est fantastique ni les coups que j'ai
dit je pensais que c'était maintenant
fait c'est pas mal
là
à
on allait avoir du mal à résister
fermement
vous pouvez toujours pas m me prend pas
peut-être que les pièces se défendent
pas l'une l'autre tu pouvais faire un
truc peut-être ne vois pas quoi comment
est-ce que tu pouvais faire enfin quand
je suis revenu à la position qu est ce
que tu pouvais faire pour l'aider en
fait pas un as mais peut-être qu'en fait
ils ont programmé comme ça pour que si
jamais tu vois ce que je veux dire ouais
ok je dors à faire un truc qu'on joue
ensemble mais on s'en va on fera
peut-être enfin là le live est censé
être fini dernière si on n'est pas
ensemble on horizons mais attends je
fais juste un test pour ma connexion
attend une seconde je l'accepté ton truc
je veux juste voir si avec le zoom ça
marche d'ici ou 6,58 à bugger de partout
au fait tu m'entends voilà à temps pour
le oui
n'entreprenne juste un t5 et j'accepte
on en fait une dernière revue synthèse
pour la connexion
comme c'était génial
enfin moi j'ai passé un bon moment la
joue et ça c'est cool bon alors là ça
craint machu picchu en bas bah non je
prépare invite mois sinon sinon tant pis
quoi nathan j'accepte ok j'ai accepté à
argentan orne ensemble ouais c'est bon
bon alors qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel
non en fait je vais jouer je sais qu'ils
commencent à toi de moi alors à temps
est ce que tu as intérêt regarde si j'ai
fait j'ai 3 toi tu lis des rats qui fait
fou prend way et au moins je sais pas on
fait des trucs
sinon je peux changer d'âme avec l'autre
l'autre ignorèrent concis mais bon on
s'en prend à blur sont probables ce
qu'en fait du coup j'étais fou dans le
viseur à tout moment je peux le mettre
en échec ça va être cool ça
de plus en plus de spectateurs sur les
passions tu as programme tv gens sont
très contents à mon avis il dit nous
dans le chat si ça vous a plu
j'ai attaqué bon bah écoutes je jure
qu'il existe un peu d'eux non ok mais je
pense que je vais à une manière très
très bas tant que germaine de trois
pièces je suis profité que tu fasses
échec comment lui faire un truc non mais
gentil champion s'est tu fais le fou
prend gesat après je fais dame français
7 et on lui on lui défonce tonnes
[Musique]
jean lassalle chaud-froid balaj est
rejugé une menace concrète s'il fait si
fait h3 tu vois mes flèches là quand je
les fais moi là bas 6 pouces je pousse
des rangs soir à des flèches pour se
parler comme ça les gens peuvent voir à
l'écran se sont par ailleurs rendus du
cou adam du fou tadam vous êtes occupe
de l'autre
d'autres bleus quoi ils moi je suis là
je suis le joueur des changements
j'attribue les mecs tout c'est de les
défoncer ci fait d'armes français cette
écoute c'est pas la fin du monde
toi tu contre attaque avec un échec déjà
ça s'était bien sûr que celui vous prend
machin ou déjà déjà iliad fait pas
demain qu'elle vaut mieux reprendre ce
truc il va éviter l'échec et je
développerai mon cavalier ans et 6 mois
à 6 ans et a créé sa dalle encore bas le
harceler qu'en double c gepa prendre sa
tour en fait je vais pousser au centre
ça pour que ça donnerait ouais c'est ce
que les directions ce que je voulais
faire qui à moi maintien harcèlement
aucune façon le vert il fait rien il ne
sert à rien et comme l'a fait
en fait après j'ai dû prendre satour
quand même
qu'est-ce que ça tombait daichi ichilov
j'encaisse bachand définitif
le gros piège auquel france organisera
et c'est bon ah bon vous attend pour
faire une autre qui dure un peu plus je
fais un test de connexion passe alain
donc si sa coupe brutalement les mecs
c'est la ville
declan elle préfère en équipe le après
il m'écrit noa noa
mais pourquoi on valide personne n'a
gagné ici sinon mais ces personnes n'est
pas l'autre si quelque part mais ce que
je voulais avoir plus de stream des
chacun 4 en fait ça que j'étais en train
de demander quand on joue là ouais ça à
toi bref ça on repousse au centre non
c'était pas mal on est en équipe
ouais ok on essaie d'aller s'en prendre
à un bleu comme dom à temps mais je suis
là et les crucifier chants catho g3
attaquerez moins fort que tu as leur
chute sinon gosses de gaffeur on peut la
refaire la stratégie du double échec là
genre tu fais bien c'est un trou 17 et
marne en asie en haute lande je te que
des 6 ou descendre nature faire des cinq
là puisqu'il a fait 3 du coup ils
bougent ramène le cavalier basile fait
eux ça marche plus souvent dû jouer au
quotidien ouais mais toi de façon c'est
bien à vous ah oui mais couvre et non ça
marche plus mais du coup je fais fiant
kétou et peut-être entendre et je suis
fou pranger ça tu fais échec et on
encaisse tout rafler la mise
ce que je peux faire maintenant déjà
annoncé jeudi prochain la belle écoute
j'ai eu un petit coup de le pendre cali
et si ce peut être mais s'y développent
awad équipe c'est seulement pour les
gens qui en abonnement premium en fait
tu m appelles ton abonnement enfin bon
j'ai envie de dire c'est peut-être un
peu le meilleur jockey long des jeux
depuis longtemps très bien fait de faire
un abonnement très très grandes choses
points comme ça on leur fait je le
prends et machin il ne paie pas d'échec
lé soir dans on est devenu des génies de
ce jeu qu'on ait des catcheurs
tous avaient les pieds des gens qu'est
ce que tu vois la déjante à moitié des
fonds c'est quoi à moitié des figures et
des gens cette position ok très bien
mais en fait c'est pas si clair avantage
matériel à dieu c'est pas si banon selon
votre niveau de vie on va me faire
cavalier h5 voilà les jeux ils font des
contre attaques qu'elle est peut-être je
faire juste ça quand un peu bloqué le
fou comme fer car 111km défoncé ici
pendant ce temps est bon je trouve cette
à la fin et je conseille et tout est
changé et moi peut-être est-ce que tu as
tu fait perdre du temps en mangeant ces
pièces c'est fantastique
par mon intuition c'est à mettre des
flèches vous attend qu'est ce que c'est
que ce cocon sens
si c'est un sens non c'est bizarre mais
je sens que ça peut avoir c'est si tu
joues un coup lui fait ça et l'autre le
coup d'après il fait ça est en forme la
dame ouais mais tu prendras ça il faut
qu'ils comprennent pas peut-être les
mecs communique aussi par flèche quoi je
sais pas mais je pense que souvent
comiques mais c'est génial ce que je
vais faire la chanson va faire plein de
vidéos en fait enfin la chaîne va
peut-être devenir un échec de machin à 4
enfin c'est non mais j'ai passé vraiment
intéressant comme j'ai en fait face je
comprends par l'artiste bon ben je
devrais dire je te dis mais en fait je
sais pas quoi jeu et notamment celle des
benjamins 3 relate jeu défensif ou non
mais attendez vous faites aux femmes
c'est qu'on n'est pas très bien
développée en fait le test je vois les
vers le grand roque mais où je veux pas
contre on ne sait pas que je total perez
je vais refoule at-on qui je laisse ça
le très bon voilà en ce temps je peux
sur bleus puisque pas très mal bleu bleu
et vert va peut-être en rdc absents qui
s'en prennent à toi là ouais et le
problème c'est qu'en fait moi j'ai gagné
du matos je suis pas très développée je
sais pas trop comment venir t'aider
en fait on a perdu pas mal de l'activité
dans notre truc et nos droits sont très
mal placés en est les seuils de cépages
autre que le soft puisque je pensais
mais bon c'est pas grand chose aura des
échecs 3 des déviations corps et bien
prendre des échecs mauricie de la
marette faut que tu feras tu viens
essayer de contrôler cette zone m j'ai
pas autrement
c'est par là que ça va se passer j'ai pu
me le monde ouais ou peut-être que vous
prends ça c'est un coup aussi non mais
j'ai pensé mais j'ai pas envie de perdre
on est fou pour le moment le cavalier
loin l'action peut-être que mon fou il
revient à en donner
parce que là en fait tu vas te prendre
fout là bas ils vont s'attaquer à deux
c'est vraiment la sermat et voilà il
faut dédier ce coup quoi bon c'est
important
c'est très bien on souffle vaste et
l'objectif est de lui faire perdre du
temps
ok faut pas qu'on oublie qu'on peut
essayer de les mater aux haïtiens bon
bah en fait
un ballon mal je sais il concède faire
un truc mais bon je suis pas sûr ceci
grâce moi j'essaie d'y être et ci fait
chaque année des covers gros coup de
rein de côté - sûrement sur -8 ok j'ai
un échec madame pour essayer de venir
contrôler la barre aussi je me ramène un
français très heureux non plus d'âme
d'air ok bon jeu contre l'euro à la
volée ouais je peux trop ce qui peut se
passer de graves fuites dont on sent par
est inquiète maintenant je suis là j'ai
fini par obliger contre attaque ce bloc
développe on le monte on dit non mais
c'est pas grave parce qu'en fait moi
j'attaque le bleu aussi pas madame elle
est très très bien placé la madame est
très bien placé parce qu'en fait je veux
dire ici qu'aux rayonner saison bah oui
c'était mon idée mais aussi je peux
essayer d'en fermer le roi je remette le
fou ici et je sais pas il va être réseau
t'es où t'es tu peux prendre aux talons
aiguilles et une douce quiétude du
quartier libre vous le peloton
ok je ramène des pièces on sait jamais
comme ça je couvre les échecs et tout va
est-ce que tu viendras année madame
là-bas ou pas non je retiens rien
d'ailleurs je vais les prendre là pour
porter des attaques
elle sut prend là en fait je pense
qu'après je peux prendre à temps dis toi
que son prochain coup je sais pas sa
charge change grand chose
peut-être que prendre ça moi je
prendrais çà il prend à 2 e
il faut avec une tour qui rendent un jab
en fait je veux qu'ils prennent et je
reprends comme ça les lattois des
écoutes je fais mon cou on joue pour le
match mon match de partout de droit un
coup aux phrases bon je veux pas trop
qui m'attaquent
ils n'ont pas assez de pia suspense je
prends sur moi je ramène ma tourangeaux
ont recontrôle plein de cases maintenant
car en fait je pense m'en être très bien
ils n'ont pas de pièces en jeu et il n'y
a plus de y'a plus rien peut-être je
jouais un truc comme ça tu vas perdre du
temps il faut donc prendre qui veulent
voter ou pas fait gaffe à ton roi je
vais me matter en fait en force est
inquiète j'échoue ça a un coût inutile
mais juste comme ça jusqu'à personnes
qui te met en double échec n'est rien
mais là ils peuvent pas payer que y est
que lui tu faire échec mais bon lui il
n'ya pas nous faire trop trop mal là où
la savoie le roi 3 4 du cavalier on est
très très heureux de ramener la tour
c'est fini tu as pris la tour et oui
c'est le mot qui est très contents de
nous voir à nouveau ici on est content
de te voir
enfournez pour 10 autres mecs dans le
tchat
bon ok
enfin là on va pu les lâcher quoi c'est
ça le truc c'est que bleu il joue plus
un coup et vert il n'a pas de pièce
c'est fini ok je le redis cavaliers
sinon nous prendre ses deux gas et comme
son maître ou alors tu peux faire ça
aussi
et sarko c'est fantastique
en fait c'est bizarre s'il faut enfin on
arrive d'être ucad mais oui du coup tu
ramènes la tour là et c'est fini mais
voilà il émane vous prend une attaque de
maths de feu quoi tout ça fait d'un gain
maïgari wes heffernan de calgary quand
on a découpé l'échiquier en 2000 on a
donné beaucoup de cases blanches foot
cause noire surnombre mais c'était pas
j'étais très heureux du ku'damm f5 en
fait parce qu'ils ont vraiment
franchement s'il avait mieux joué on se
faisait maths et de l'autre côté mais
bon c'était fantastique comme chez moi
mais je pense qu'on fera des vidéos pour
la chaîne en fait un femme
ouais bah du coup c'est là je pense
qu'elle est je pense qu'avec son épouse
ils éprouveraient des chèques fait très
attention ça va être sympa à la chaîne
va être que ça maintenant il faut le
savoir maximum au prix de pomone au
roulement
non mais enfin j'ai ça fait longtemps
que j'avais pas autant qu'il fait à
jouer un nouveau truc face j'ai vraiment
aimé c'était vraiment drôle
on fait quoi on laisse les gens ouais on
va passer une bonne soirée les mecs à
l'état où je pense que je suis encore
avec la cam ou quoi tristan qui me dit
que c'est génial à regarder un peu nos
trucs toujours comme dans un rêve
une vidéo là à les voir aller sur les
mecs on va filmer des trucs là